something really special happened when
we reunited for Avatar 2. so I may were
always just very close and that gave us
absolute freedom to just bounce off each
other and enjoy the ride
okay don't think they quite realized how
much they had been in training for this
movie for the past 13 years as parents
we couldn't have planned it better if
I'd said okay what I need you guys to do
is find somebody you really love and get
married and have some children and
that's your prep for the next movie
she's now had several children I've had
several children when we get back into
this world it's like putting on an old
pair of gloves you just have a trust for
each other I think they started to get
it when they read the script but I don't
think they really got it until they were
on set with the young cast that play
their children and realize oh yeah I've
said that
that's enough don't make me come over
there but given Jake and the teary kids
this one opens up all the trials and
tribulations that come with having
family
fakes are higher
now their children are everything
they've managed to find their own
version of Happiness to the sky people
come back